on reste sur cette thématique d'économie
d'énergie et de pouvoir d'achat comment
réduire la facture on voit ça avec notre
invité ce soir on sort Marie-Claude
fourrier bonsoir présidente de
l'association de consommateurs CLCV en
Indre-et-Loire avant de parler
d'économie d'énergie on va regarder
c'est les images qui font écho aux
propos du maire de tour à l'instant qui
parlait de bouillonnement social image
tournée lundi à la Rabière à jouer les
tours manifestation d'habitants contre
la hausse brutale de leur charge
locative de 50 à 250 euros
supplémentaires par mois cette colère
sociale cette détresse sociale vous la
rencontrez aussi dans vos permanences
c'est LCV oui d'autant plus cette
semaine avec justement ce qui s'est
passé à jouer les tours à l'arabière
vous étiez oui où nous étions auprès des
locataires une centaine de locataires
effectivement qui ont vu leur charge
augmentée de 200 euros sur un mois c'est
absolument
impossible quoi vous avez d'autres
exemples comme celui-ci oui alors par
exemple dans un T4 une personne qui paye
340 euros de loyer a eu 350 euros de
charges donc c'est ça n'arrive jamais
d'ordinaire
quand il y en a etc quoi avait demandé
le blocage des loyers à un moment donné
vous aviez obtenu bien de cause alors
à Tours Val Touraine Habitat va le faire
l'autre jour à la métropole où il y
avait une réunion j'ai demandé à puisque
tous les bailleurs sociaux étaient
réunis j'ai demandé à ce que ça soit
pour l'ensemble de tous les bailleurs
sociaux d'Indre-et-Loire qui est ce
blocage au niveau oui et surtout des
loyers puisque il y a il est il est
convenu qu'il y ait 360 d'augmentation
de loyer et c'est absolument infaisable
à l'heure actuelle pour les locataires
6%
effectivement on va revenir sur ces
incitations à la sobriété des voilées
hier par le gouvernement pour éviter des
coupures d'électricité cet hiver alors
un geste pour la planète pour les
économies d'énergie et du point de vue
du portefeuille cette fois quelles sont
les gains que l'on peut attendre de
certaines de ces mesures comme baisser
la température etc alors par exemple
baisser la température d'un degré c'est
quand même 7% sur le budget acheter des
appareils électroménagers par exemple
quand on a échangé qui soit en a ou A++
bon c'est toujours ça
d'autre part toujours en appareil
électroménager prendre ce que l'on a
besoin par exemple un ménage à pas
besoin d'un 8 kg j'entends on lave-linge
par exemple
au point de vue lessive c'est pareil
faire une lessive à 32°c
c'est quand même beaucoup plus
avantageux un lave-vaisselle en écho
aussi par exemple ce n'est que des
exemples permet donc de faire des
économies plutôt importantes le
gouvernement qui a renouvelé il y a deux
semaines son bouclier énergétique la
facture de gaz et d'électricité non
manquera que entre guillemets de 15%
l'an prochain pour les consommateurs au
tarif réglementé est-ce qu'on peut
revenir au tarif réglementé pour après
avoir souscrit à une offre de marché par
exemple alors au point de vue de
l'électricité oui on peut tout à fait
EDF
un problème par contre gaz on ne peut
pas si on a quitté le tarif réglementé
on ne peut pas revenir au tarif
réglementé donc il faut faire vraiment
très très attention à ce que l'on nous
propose les tarifs de gaz qui comme vous
le savez
viendront à leur fin au 30 juin 2023 par
rapport au tarif règlementé et à l'heure
actuelle bah il y a beaucoup de
fournisseurs
alternatifs je dirais qui sont sur le
marché et qui proposent déjà j'irai
presque tout et n'importe quoi donc faut
faire attention même si vous propose une
offre par exemple à 10% de moins que le
tarif actuel faire attention à côté que
l'abonnement ne soit pas beaucoup plus
important merci beaucoup Marie-Claude
fourrier merci d'être venu ce soir sur
notre plateau